- [Kim] Hi, this is Kim from Khan Academy.
Today we're learning more
about the Ninth Amendment
to the US Constitution, which reads,
"The enumeration in the
Constitution, of certain rights,
"shall not be construed
to deny or disparage
"others retained by the people."
This, along with the Tenth Amendment,
doesn't protect a specific right,
like freedom of religion or
due process under the law,
but rather, advances an interpretation
of the scope of the Constitution
and of government power.
To learn more about the Ninth Amendment,
I talked with two experts.
Kurt Lash is the E. Claiborne Robins
Distinguished Chair in Law
at the University of
Richmond School of Law.
Jeffrey Rosen is the president and CEO
of the National Constitution Center.
He has written extensively
on the history of the Supreme Court.
Professor Lash, can you
tell us a little bit more
about this amendment?
Why did the Framers include this amendment
in the first place?
- [Kurt] The Ninth Amendment,
like rest of the Bill of Rights,
was added at the insistence of the states.
Although the advocates of
the proposed Constitution
had claimed that the national government
would have only limited enumerated power,
the state ratifying
conventions wanted that promise
put in writing.
- [Jeffrey] Originally, the Constitution
didn't contain a bill of rights
'cause James Madison said a bill of rights
would be unnecessary or dangerous,
unnecessary 'cause the Constitution itself
was a bill of rights.
It only granted Congress limited powers,
and therefore, Congress had no power
to infringe free speech, for
example, or religious liberty,
and therefore, wouldn't be able to do so,
and dangerous, Madison said,
because if you had a bill of rights,
people might wrongly assume
that if a right wasn't written down,
it wasn't protected, but in response
to objections by anti-federalists,
that is those opposed to the ratification
of the Constitution, led by
George Mason of Virginia,
as well as Edmund Randolph of Virginia
and Elbridge Gerry of Massachusetts,
so those three guys said, "Hey,
"unless we include a bill of rights
"for greater security and safety,
"then we don't think the
Constitution should be ratified."
In response to their objections
and those in ratifying conventions,
many of which demanded a bill of rights,
Madison changed his mind, and he
included a bill of rights,
which he cut-and-pasted
from revolutionary-era
state constitutions,
and viewers and listeners
can check those out
at the Interactive Constitution.
Then that raised an interpretive problem.
Madison and others were worried,
if you just had a limited
list of rights, 10
amendments in particular,
protecting particular rights,
people might assume that if
a right wasn't written down,
then it wasn't protected, and the Framers
didn't want you to reach that conclusion
because they believed that
our rights come from God
or nature and not from government.
Thomas Jefferson, in the
Declaration of Independence,
said we're all endowed by our Creator
with certain unalienable rights.
- [Kurt] When you look
at these amendments,
our first 10 amendments,
you'll notice that some
address specific issues,
like speech and the right to bear arms.
The last two amendments
on that list, however,
address broader issues of
Constitutional interpretation.
These are rules of construction.
The Tenth Amendment
declares that all powers
not delegated away
remain under the control of
the people in the states.
The Ninth Amendment addresses the problem
potentially raised by adding
this list in a bill of rights.
The Ninth Amendment tells
us that just because
the Constitution lists certain important
limitations on federal power,
this doesn't mean that
the federal government
has otherwise unlimited power,
or, as the Ninth Amendment puts it,
"The enumeration in the
Constitution, of certain rights,
"shall not be construed
to deny or disparage
"others retained by the people."
In this way, those two
last rules of construction
ensure that every subject not placed
under the control of
the national government
would remain under the control
of the people in the states
and remain there as a matter of right.
These amendments protect
the people's retained right
to local self government.
- [Jeffrey] I talked a
bit about natural rights
because that same notion of the idea
that you retain natural rights
when you move from the state of nature
to the civil society is picked up
in the language of the Ninth Amendment,
which says that the
enumeration "of certain rights
"shall not be construed to
deny or disparage others
"retained by the people,"
so one big theory
of the Ninth Amendment is that it refers
to these natural rights
that come from God or nature
and that you retain during the transition
from the state of nature to civil society.
- [Kim] Can you give us a few examples
of what those unenumerated rights
that people have debated have been?
- [Jeffrey] The paradigmatic source
for identifying what
unenumerated rights are protected
is a case called Corfield v. Coryell.
It was decided in the early 19th Century,
and it was cited repeatedly
by the people who wrote
the Privileges or Immunities Clause
to the Fourteenth Amendment
to the Constitution,
and basically, the Privileges
or Immunities Clause says that
no state shall abridge the
privileges or immunities
of citizens of the United States,
and the question is what are
those privileges or immunities?
In trying to define them, John Bingham,
who wrote the Fourteenth Amendment,
and a lot of other people
said, "Well, some of the
privileges or immunities
"include the rights written
down in the Bill of Rights,
"but others are not written
"and you can find them in the
Corfield and Coryell case.
They're rights that are fundamental.
They're uniform from state to state,
and they've been considered basic rights
of Americans from the beginning.
Some of these rights
include the right to make
and enforce contracts, to sue and be sued,
to have basic economic rights,
and also to have the benefit
of the writ of habeas corpus,
which is in the original Constitution,
and that's the right to
challenge the constitutionality
of your conviction.
It's in the original Constitution,
but not in the Bill of Rights.
Those are just some examples
of the unenumerated economic rights
that the Framers of the
Fourteenth Amendment considered
to be protected by the
Fourteenth Amendment
and by implication, by
the Ninth Amendment too,
'cause they are natural rights,
as we heard Roger Sherman
say, the basic rights
of acquiring and possessing property
and obtaining happiness and safety,
those are some of those rights.
- [Kurt] The Ninth Amendment
raises the difficult issue
of how exactly you determine
what the rights are
that are actually retained by the people.
The text of the Ninth Amendment itself
tells us very little
about the specific content
of our retained rights, but
in fact, these retained rights
are as numerous as the stars in the sky.
They include everything from wearing a hat
to walking on the sidewalk,
to purchasing life insurance,
or determining where
you can park your car,
or what classes should be
offered in the local high school,
basically everything that
was never meant to be handed
to the control of the national
government, all of these
are rights retained to the control
of the people in the several states,
and all of these rights will be protected
if you limit the scope of federal power.
A limited interpretation
of the Commerce Clause,
for example, preserves the
people's retained right
to establish local educational policy
and to pass all manner of
local civil rights legislation
that's not expressly covered
by the federal Constitution.
The greater the limits on federal power,
the greater the freedom
of local communities.
By making a limited interpretation
of federal power a right,
this ensure the matter can
be litigated in federal court
and not just left to political compromise.
Over time, courts will
produce a body of law
that invalidates attempts
by the federal government
to regulate our lives in forbidden ways,
such as not having the power
under the Commerce Clause
to force us to purchase
private health insurance
or not having the power to
commandeer state official
and force them to enforce
federal immigration policy.
- [Kim] Does this refer
back to some extent
to kind of the common law of England
and the things that were considered
the natural rights of Englishmen?
- [Jeffrey] Yes, it does,
although we should distinguish it
if we're gonna be
precise, which we should.
Not all of the common
law rights of Englishmen
were natural rights.
Common law rights, basically, are rights
that were traditionally
protected by English law.
They're rights that had been recognized
by English judges over centuries.
Natural rights come from God
or nature, not from government.
There's overlap between those groups,
but there might've been some
common law rights of English
people that were recognized by tradition,
like the right to jury trial, for example.
That's not a natural
right 'cause there are no
juries in the state of nature.
There are just people
who are (laughs) imagining
forming governments.
It makes it a little tricky,
but it's actually not
that analytically tricky,
and it's so interesting
that over and over
again, the Framers said,
"You know, this is just,
everyone knows what these
"natural rights are."
They're the ones that are recognized
in Corfield and Coryell,
and then other enumerated rights
might include the common
law rights of Englishmen,
but it was a pretty short list,
and the best way to just
figure out which rights
were natural, go to the
Interactive Constitution,
click down, and look at the
Virginia Declaration of Rights.
Look at the Massachusetts
Constitution of 1780,
the New Hampshire Constitution.
It has this beautiful preamble
about what a natural right is,
and you'll just see that all
of these state constitutions
are recognizing the same natural
rights over and over again.
- [Kim] Has the Supreme
Court ever decided a case
based on the Ninth Amendment?
- [Kurt] The first judicial opinion
was actually written by
Justice Joseph Story,
one of the most famous
justices in American history.
In his opinion in Houston Against Moore,
decided in 1820, Story
explained that the spirit
and letter of the Ninth Amendment
called for the limited interpreting
of the scope of federal power
in order to avoid
interfering with state laws
regarding the local militia.
In fact, it wasn't until the 20th Century
that you find scholars and justices
trying to invert the Ninth Amendment
in a manner that allowed or even required
federal interference with local policies.
In Griswold against
Connecticut, for example,
Justice Arthur Goldberg argued
that the Ninth Amendment
supported the court's
invalidation of state contraception laws.
- [Jeffrey] Douglas says in
this case that the Constitution
and the particular rights
and the Bill of Rights
include certain penumbras
formed be emanations,
from the particular
guarantees that may create
broader unenumerated rights,
and privacy was one of them.
Douglas says privacy is
protected in different ways
in different parts of the Bill of Rights.
The Fourth Amendment
protects our right against
unreasonable searches and seizures.
The Third Amendment protects the right
not to have soldiers
quartered in the home.
The First Amendment protects
a right of freedom of association,
and from these particular
expressions of privacy,
Douglas extracted, or inferred,
a broader and more
sweeping right of privacy,
which could be extended to cover
a married couple's right
to use contraception.
- [Kim] When the Bill
of Rights was ratified
in the late 18th Century, it only applied
to the federal government.
It was not until after the Civil War,
in the late 1860s and early 1870s,
that the Fourteenth Amendment applied some
of the protections of the Bill of Rights
to state governments.
How does the Fourteenth Amendment
impact our understanding
of the Ninth Amendment?
- [Kurt] Most Constitutional
historians believe
that the Privileges or Immunities Clause
was originally understood as applying
the first eight amendments
against the states.
What of the Ninth Amendment?
Is it possible
that the Privileges or Immunities Clause
turns the Ninth Amendment from a provision
protecting local government to one
that interferes with local government?
Many libertarian scholars believe so.
A close look at the
historical record, however,
shows that this is not likely.
To begin with, John
Bingham, the man who framed
the Privileges or Immunities Clause,
publicly declared at the
House of Representatives
that the Privileges or Immunities Clause
made the first eight amendments
enforceable against the states.
He said nothing about either
the Ninth or Tenth Amendments.
Meanwhile, in the Senate,
the man who introduced the proposed
Fourteenth Amendment to
his college, Jacob Howard,
also said that the Privileges
or Immunities Clause
would apply the first eight
amendments against the states,
and he too said nothing about
the Ninth or Tenth Amendments.
Finally, the public that
debated and ratified
the Fourteenth Amendment
remained broadly committed
to the federalist
principle of dividing power
between the state and local governments.
It had been the slave-holding rebel sates
that had violated this principle
by demanding that slavery be
enforced throughout the nation,
regardless of local freedom laws.
If we look at the period
in which they adopted
the Fourteenth Amendment, it
appears that that ammendment
did, in fact, apply the textual rights
of the first eight amendments
against the states,
but it left everything
else to local control,
subject only to the
requirements of due process
and equal protection.
- [Jeffrey] The Ninth
Amendment, at the very least,
is a question of interpretation.
It says don't assume that if
a right isn't written down
it's not protected.
When the late Robert
Bork, who was nominated
to the Supreme Court in
1987 but didn't get through,
said that the Ninth
Amendment should be treated
as an ink blot because we can't know
what rights are actually
protected by the Ninth Amendment,
it should be ignored, that can't be right.
That's the one thing that
Madison said don't do.
Don't assume that if the
right isn't written down,
it's not protected.
Saying that that matter of construction
is important and that there are certain
rights not enumerated in the Constitution
that are protected doesn't
tell us which rights
are protected, and that's
where all of the action
and all of the drama and
all of the excitement
and Constitutional interpretation
in the 20th and 21st
Century has come from.
How do we identify
the rights that are not written
down, are not enumerated,
but are protected?
There's a whole lot to say about that.
In fact, that's why we
teach Constitutional law,
is to study the methodologies
of interpretation
that lead people to different conclusions
about which unenumerated
rights are protected.
- [Kim] We've learned
that the Ninth Amendment
served as an assurance
that the Bill of Rights
was not an exhaustive list
of the rights retained by
the people or the states.
How can you protect unenumerated rights,
which, by their very definition,
aren't named in the Constitution?
Kurt Lash sees the original meaning
of the Ninth Amendment as a
restriction on federal power.
Jeff Rosen reminds us that
although it's difficult to tell
which rights the Framers intended
to protect with the Ninth Amendment,
it's likely that those rights
included the same natural,
unalienable rights
enshrined in the
Declaration of Independence.
To learn more about the Ninth Amendment,
visit the National Constitution Center's
Interactive Constitution
in Khan Academy resources
on US government and politics.